before i start i want to mention my
sponsor for this video
portuguese pod 101 pod 101 courses are
among my favorite language tools
especially for listening and shadowing
why not click the link in the
description for a free account and give
it a try
i'm sure you've heard of the portuguese
language but i know that some of you
have never heard of the galician
language
galego but today i'm going to talk about
galician and its connection to
portuguese
galician is a member of the ibero
romance branch of the romance language
family
it's spoken by around 2.4 million people
most of them in galicia
galicia is an autonomous region in
northwestern spain that borders portugal
to the south
galician is co-official with spanish in
galicia
and by spanish i mean castilian galician
is a sister language of portuguese
with the two of them sharing a common
origin beginning in around the 9th
century
there was a romance language now
referred to as galician portuguese
though at the time it was simply
considered a form of vulgar latin
this language began diverging into
distinct galician and portuguese
languages during the 13th century
the county of portugal was originally
part of the kingdom of galicia which was
part of the kingdom of leon
but it became the independent kingdom of
portugal in the year 1139
and it began expanding its borders
southward while they seized territory
from the moors as the reconquista
progressed
naturally they brought their language
with them towards the south
in the year 1230 leon including galicia
was incorporated into the crown of
castile
and they were incorporated into spain in
the year 1516.
the varieties of galician portuguese
spoken to the north in galicia
and those spoken to the south in
portugal began to gradually become more
distinct until they were eventually
thought of as separate languages
because galician and portuguese are
still so similar today
and have a high level of mutual
intelligibility you may hear some people
say that galician is a dialect of
portuguese but that's not accurate
because it makes it sound like galician
developed from portuguese when in
reality they both developed from the
same medieval language referred to as
galician portuguese
people really only say that galician is
a dialect of portuguese because
portuguese is the more well-known
language
the more famous language so instead you
could say that there are two varieties
of the same language
rather than saying galician is a dialect
of portuguese
and indeed they are more similar than
dialects of some languages are
but they have separate standard
languages and galician is associated
with a culture that's distinct from the
portuguese and from their former
colonies
in many cases these are the two factors
that determine whether two similar ways
of communicating
are dialects of a single language or
distinct languages
though there is no universal criteria
for how to determine that
they're very similar in terms of grammar
and vocabulary but there are lots of
little differences in their phonology
and orthography
in large part due to the influence of
castilian on galician
amiga case
there are numerous differences in the
consonant sounds of galician and
portuguese
there's no v sound in galician though
there is in portuguese
in galician b and v represent the same
phoneme
buh as in spanish it's ba or
a voiced bilabial fricative note that
this happens in northern portugal too
for example the word for cow in galician
in standard pronunciation at the
beginning of a word like this it would
be
ba but the speaker on the recording
seems to say it as a fricative
listen to the pronunciation on this
galician dictionary site
baka
and in portuguese vodka the word for
cave
in galician and in portuguese
note that this word is used slightly
differently in portuguese
meaning cavity cavern or grave sometimes
the difference is also reflected in
writing
for example the word for edible in
galician
and in portuguese another difference
in portuguese s is pronounced z between
vowels
but not in galician for example the word
for house
in galician and in portuguese
the word for thing in galician
and in portuguese causa
in galician c represents a voiceless
dental fricative
before i and e as in spanish for example
the word for five
in galician cinco and in portuguese
another one in galician the digraph ch
is pronounced in portuguese it's
for example the verb meaning to call in
galician
and in portuguese another difference
the galician rhotic consonant is like
the spanish one
a trill or a tap there is no guttural
rhodic sound like in portuguese
for example the word meaning rich in
galician
and in portuguese in galician there are
no phonemic nasal vowels
there are vowels that become nasalized
due to the surrounding environment
in other words they're next to a nasal
consonant but there are no pairs of
words that are distinguished by vowel
nasality
and vowel nasality is not a part of
galician orthography
the word for bread in galician and in
portuguese
here you can see that the nasal vowel
that existed in galician portuguese has
been lost in galatian
but remains in portuguese in galician
there's a nasal consonant instead
note that when n comes at the end of a
word in galician it's pronounced
rather than n also notice the loss of
the diphthong
the word for brother in galatians
and in portuguese is the standard form
and used in western dialects
while irmo is used in central and
eastern dialects
iramang seems more similar to castilian
hermano
judging by its nasal consonant and lack
of a diphthong
irumau retains the diphthong that is
also found in portuguese
but when there's a diphthong in galician
there's no nasal whether a vowel or a
consonant
we can see this in numerous words such
as the word for
hand and the plural form hands in
galician
mang mans mao
mouse in portuguese
some of the nouns in portuguese with
this nasal diphthong have a different
plural form
but in galician the plural remains the
same simply add
s
there are also cognates that have
differences in nasal consonants
like the differences in the following
determiners the words for ah
or one in galician oh
note that the first pair of words in
galician is standard
and the second pair is dialectal and now
in portuguese
the words for no know as a determiner in
galician
ningun
here are a few other differences in
pronunciation and orthography
galician uses n with a tilde and ll
instead of nh and lh as in portuguese
for example the words for line in
galician linea
and in portuguese linha the word for red
in galician and in portuguese
you will notice that cognate words are
often written with different vowel
accents
or one will have a written accent and
the other won't for example the word
from moon
in galician and in portuguese
and the verb form meaning i ate or i was
eating
in galician and in portuguese
galician uses the letter x to represent
the sound
shi a voiceless post-alveolar fricative
but galician doesn't have a voiced
post-alveolar fricative
so you'll notice words with a z sound in
portuguese being used in galician
with a sound represented by x for
example the word for people
in galician and in portuguese
the word for window in galician chanel
and in portuguese janella
you'll also see some slightly different
word forms for example when prepositions
contract with articles
in galician polo and in portuguese
this combination of preposition plus
article means by the
or for the along with some other
meanings here's an example sentence
meaning i did that for the money
eu
you can see a couple of other
differences here as well notice the
different spelling of the demonstrative
article meaning that
also notice the different forms the verb
takes in either language
fichen versus fiz both are the first
person singular preterit form of cognate
verbs
galician father and portuguese fazer
verbs often take the same forms in both
languages but in this case they're a
little different
let's look at a somewhat bigger
difference in verbs in galician the past
perfect tense isn't conjugated with an
auxiliary verb
here's a sentence meaning the teacher
had already arrived in galician
professor word for word it's the teacher
already had arrived this verb form here
is the third person singular plu perfect
form
portuguese does actually have that same
tense that is used in galatian but it's
not used in spoken portuguese
word for word it's the teacher already
had arrived
here we can see that the past perfect is
expressed with a compound tense
the auxiliary verb is the first person
singular imperfect form of
aver which means have at least as an
auxiliary verb
it's followed by the masculine singular
past participle of
shigar galician doesn't use compound
tenses in general
simple tenses are usually used in their
place
pronouns galician and european
portuguese pronouns are generally the
same
though there are some little differences
in portuguese the second person's
singular familiar pronoun is
tu and in galician it's t and in
portuguese there is just one equivalent
pronoun for both direct and indirect
objects
two in galician there are two te and che
in standard galatian there are both but
depending on the dialect
many speakers use either te for both
direct object and indirect
object or che for both direct object and
indirect object
now let's look at some more example
sentences and break them down
these sentences mean galician is a
sister language of portuguese
in portuguese
word for word it's the galician is a
language
sister of the portuguese notice the
difference in the indefinite article
that we saw earlier
notice that the galician article has the
letters nh
which represent the sound while the
portuguese article simply has an m
representing a m sound next we see an
acute accent marking the portuguese word
lingua but not in galician next notice
the differences in the word for sister
similar to the words for brother that we
saw earlier the galician word has no
nasal vowel
yet notice the acute accent above the
letter a
we also see different diacritics over
the words for portuguese
diacritics in galician are much simpler
than in portuguese
vowels can take only an acute accent
which usually represents the primary
stress of the word when it's not in the
default location
in portuguese the acute accent is used
to show primary stress
but only for low vowels while the
circumflex indicates the equivalent high
vowel
then there is e which is always a high
vowel the grav accent is used to show
the contraction of two side by side
vowels
normally the preposition a and an
article or demonstrative pronoun
and of course portuguese uses this
symbol to indicate phonemic nasal vowels
but this doesn't occur in galician one
last thing to note in this sentence here
we see that the combination of the
preposition
or de and the definite article o is the
same in both languages
remember we saw some earlier that have
different forms but in this case they're
the same
one more pair of sentences these
sentences mean i've been working for 12
hours
in portuguese word for word it's i am
to work there is 12 hours
ending
word for word it's i take working 12
hours
but the woman you hear in the video told
me that it might be more natural for a
galician to use the word for a dozen
instead
in this pair of sentences we see some
more significant differences
first of all the way of expressing the
present perfect progressive meaning in
either language is different
in european portuguese it would be like
this with the present tense of the
auxiliary verb
meaning to be plus the infinitive of the
main verb
this is actually the present progressive
form but it's often used where the
present perfect progressive
would be used in english and in
brazilian portuguese this would be the
present participle rather than the
infinitive
here you see the first person singular
present tense of the verb
levar which means take though it is also
used with the meaning of
to spend time doing something it's
followed by the present participle so
the way it's expressed is like saying
i spend 12 hours working in portuguese
levar is not really used in this way
with the meaning of spend time doing
let's take a look at how that verb levar
is conjugated in the present tense in
both languages
to see how similar the forms are ilev to
levis
11. nozzle vamps fossil vice
notice that only the second and third
person plural forms are slightly
different
and in pronunciation the sound
represented by v is different
you can probably see why galician and
portuguese share a very high degree of
mutual intelligibility
and by the way that's also true for
brazilian portuguese even though the
samples in the video were for european
portuguese
in fact some people say that galician is
closer to brazilian portuguese than it
is to european portuguese
are galician and portuguese varieties of
a single language
well linguistically they genuinely seem
similar enough that they could be
considered a single language
and as i mentioned before you could say
that together they form
one pluricentric language one language
with multiple standard varieties
but as i mentioned before it's often
cultural or national identity that
determines what is considered a distinct
language versus a variety of a language
if history had taken a different turn
and galicia and portugal today formed a
single country
i'm sure that all galician dialects and
all portuguese dialects would be
considered varieties of a single
language
would it be called deletion or
portuguese or something else
who knows the question of the day to
native speakers of portuguese and
galician
in your opinion do you speak varieties
of a single language
or do you speak different languages why
do you think so
and to other people disregarding
cultural issues do you think they seem
like different languages
or varieties of a single language and
this is the part of the video when i say
thanks to my patreon patrons
especially my top tier patrons whose
names appear on the screen
i want to give a very special thanks to
them and to everyone thank you for
watching
and have a nice day
[Music]
oh you're still here okay well here's
one more pair of sentences for you
these sentences mean i want to buy some
clothes in galician
and in portuguese word for word
i want buy some clothes these sentences
are quite similar but you can see that
the word for bi
is different the galician word miracad
used to have the meaning of
trade as in to buy and sell goods
according to several dictionaries
miracad still exists in portuguese with
that meaning too
though it seems it's not commonly used
anymore the portuguese word komprad
is also used in galician as a synonym of
mercad
we also see the slightly different
determiners that we saw before
galician and portuguese
[Music]
you